jean-paul chang bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france on va voir avec
vous et le point de vue de la chine dans
ses relations commerciales avec les
états unis on le disait washington qui
entend entamer des discussions franches
avec pékin sur le commerce en faisant
preuve de fermeté finalement la
politique de joe biden est ce que c'est
la même que donald trump en matière de
commerce avec la chine
je pense que les nuances parce que
l'administration by donne en tout cas
son équipe juge les mesures prises or
l'administration de biden comme
chaotique est au fond une efficace donc
on voit bien que eux ils font
aujourd'hui preuve dans lequel plus de
pragmatisme
ils veulent d'abord il ya deux objectifs
qui sont à court terme un premier
objectif faire un peigne et la parole
aux chinois sur le fait d'augmenter de
200 milliards d'importations aux
produits américains avant la fin de 2009
21 or le moment les chinois ont en tout
cas déjà commandé 89% des produits
agricoles américains sur les noms sur la
commune cité les premiers par contre que
les produits énergétiques c'est à dire
20 city fier et c'est en fait que les
chinois ont tenu la promesse à ce jour à
la 42 1% donc là dessus à une marche
effectivement accompli encore donc les
discussions à venir entre catherine et
l'initiation de chinoise va porter sur
ce point bien entendu le fait de l'échec
et les chinois ont pu accomplir la
promesse autres qu'ils aiment chasser le
privé c'est le pragmatisme l'année que
sur le court terme mais je pense
qu'elles risquent à son bail de
l'exercice est ainsi que contre que que
les choses sont en prise à pékin ces
canalisations d'ailleurs ne pas rater la
reprise donc la sortie de la crise la
déco bild en termes de relance
économique et qu' ils ont besoin et
évidemment du marché chinois et la
coopération chinoise là dessus
donc il faut manier la carotte et le
bâton on parle bien dans le
discours de catherine taille de cible
certaines exemptions de de droits de
douane ça veut dire qu'on fait c'est
qu'ils sont un peu moins faim car c'est
peut-être aussi sous la pression en
effet du milieu des affaires américain
des industriels américains parce qu'il
faut savoir quand même énormément et
leurs démarches de produits
intermédiaires viennent de chine pour
l'industrie américaine le là dessus 4
int a utilisé une formule relativement
intéressante elle a dit on va pas
continuer à découpler réfléchi mais il
s'agit de re couplée avec la chine mais
avec des critères effectivement le
marché l'ouvert de copier des règles
qu'on commence les cinémas donc ça veut
dire quoi finalement servir quoi ça veut
dire que ces taxes douanières sur les
produits chinois finalement elle
sanctionne autant les états unis que la
chine
dont 95% ont effectivement deux de ses
leaders sont payés par les indices hier
américain des consommateurs américains
bien sûr donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle les critiques l'administration
des douanes juge que les mesures là
simplement de hausser le tarif douanier
ne sont pas réellement efficace alors du
côté de la maison blanche on affirma que
le but n'est pas d'aggraver les tensions
commerciales avec la chine mais les
états unis sont prêts à utiliser le site
toute la gamme d'outils dans quel état
d'esprit aujourd'hui le gouvernement
chinois qu'ils aillent à la crainte
d'éventuelles nouvelles sanctions
en tout cas on rentre dans une phase de
discussion ce qui est déjà un peu
nouveau contenu la tension qui règne
actuellement sur les autres aspects des
relations sino-américaines
politiques notamment idéologiques
militaires etc donc il a une fenêtre
effectivement de discussion aussi que
les discussions ont déjà eu lieu par
exemple c'est là qu'est le problème
climatique quand tu as de kerry a été
enrichie d'une première fois ainsi que
le secrétaire d'état adjoint américain
et un café un voyage à tianjin les
discussions étaient restées relativement
durs des chinois en tout cas
j'étais mécontent du fait que nature si
l'attitude tout qu'américains et la
chine à la suite de la migration
ces discussions commerciales c'est une
occasion au lieu de pays de se parler un
peu plus apaisé
doudou quand même une perspective qui a
été bien accueilli par les milieux
d'affaires aussi bien américains que
chinois parce qu'ils espèrent
effectivement que cécile ayant comme des
changements sur les tarifs douaniers
alors il ya aussi ces accusations de la
part de washington de vol de la
propriété intellectuelle alors de quoi
parlent les américains et qu'est-ce
qu'on dise les chinois les chinois
c'est une attaque système est il que si
ça fait l'objet des discussions depuis
toujours entre le chine et les états
unis les chinois ont dû sous la pression
quand même avec étrangères depuis
quelques années mettre en place comme
beaucoup beaucoup de législation et les
réglementations pour montrer patte
blanche sur les problèmes de respect des
droits de propriété intellectuelle
ceci dit les chinois affirme aussi que
la prochaine et qu'elle consiste
finalement
freiner la croissance chinoise et la
freiner la l'innovation chinoise
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas catherine times
et le secrétaire d'état au commerce
américain qui a déclaré sa voix à un
journal il ya des gens là disent qu' il
faut faire l'alliance al clé les alliés
et les pays
européens pour ralentir l'innovation
chinoise parce qu'elle ce qui est quand
même un objectif que l'étrange donc les
chinois considèrent comme fait tout est
fait pour que les etats unis gardent la
première place est en fait ce qu'ils
veulent c'est le cas contraire la
croissance chinoise et les chinois
consacre à ce moment là c'est c'est une
atteinte portée à agra fondamental de
chine de se développer alors vous
l'évoquez à l'instant les états unis
veulent s'appuyer sur d'autres
partenaires sur d'autres partenaires et
comptent sur les alliés européens pour
les suivre quelle est la teneur
aujourd'hui les relations économiques
entre la chine et l'europe plutôt bonne
après la crise ce poste que id le
problème c'est que il ya changement
politique même en europe sur l'échiquier
politique
notamment à l'allemagne dont quelques
chinois sont quand même un peu prudent
et dans l'expectative
il espère que les choses vont continuer
mais il voit bien que il ya une sorte de
pause depuis l'arrivée de baden à la
présidence américaine notamment lorsque
le parlement européen a bloqué et la
discussion sur l'accord d'investissement
une protection des talismans qu'elle
était conclue avant la fin de l'année
2020 entre la chine et l'union
européenne là dessus les chinois sont
certes inquiet mais pas trop parce que
comme les états unis d'ailleurs l'europe
ne peut pas vraiment se permettre le
seul deux comédiens de l des couples est
complètement sur l'économie finalement
de aussi bien à cause de la taille du
marché chinois qui est une quête qui a
une importance est absolument essentiel
pour les économies européenne et
américaine
et deuxièmement le fait que la chine de
l'est malgré tout les jeunes du monde
qui fournit énormément de produits
intermédiaires pour toutes nos
industries
merci beaucoup jean-paul femmes pour
votre et votre éclairage ce matin sur
rtl france je rappelle vous êtes
économiste spécialiste de la chine